jiren what's up buddy how you been have
i have been doing well how about
yourself yeah i'm i'm bummed i couldn't
make that retreat over the week and i
know you mentioned it and i think i
think paul and a couple other guys went
yeah i i love that kind of stuff you
would like i'm into that stuff it was it
was a freaking hit and the facilitator
was phenomenal i'm telling you man you
would love it i'll i'll i'll definitely
make sure that i save a spot for you
when i do the next one
yeah yeah sounds good yeah i'm
definitely that kind of stuff it's been
a while since i've had a hero's journey
i'll do like micro dosing because it's
me and myself and maybe like a plus one
but uh yeah when it's a guided journey
it's it's a whole different experience
and i definitely enjoy those yeah so on
the topic of uh the friend groups
that got some stories going to my head
because i'm so far into my transition
that i forget about that like oh god i
used to have all these problems um and
guys that follow you and that follow me
they know
kind of my origin story more or less
that uh in some nation i ended up
getting married to a really pretty
colombian girl who uh once the green
card game she came she was out uh
started doing the oh i don't know we're
just not working type thing and then i
went to the marriage counseling of
course she didn't join uh eventually got
to the well i don't feel safe around
here i don't know where we're going and
this should have been a
a key indicator at the time so this girl
is colombian she was latin so obviously
they have large friend groups a lot of
their friends with their family members
women don't usually go out unaccompanied
unless there's male company in the
groups all those kind of cultural things
so i know at one point
we lived in the same town she she was no
longer cohabitating with me and she
invited me out to a nightclub with her
and her girlfriends and uh some of her
male cousins so i'm like all right yeah
cool i'll go i had a buddy in town too
so like yeah i'll bring him out you know
the girls are all cute and they're fun
and yeah i hadn't seen my wife in a
while at that point uh probably well
like a week or so
so we we went out and i noticed really
quickly and i i remember making a
comment to her i was like hey your your
best friend seems really into me like
she was really touchy and feely and i
was like hey just wanna let you know
like there's nothing going on here um
turns out i found out way after the fact
that uh
the best friend's little brother was
actually banging my wife who she later
ended up shacking up with and i think
she pulled the same scam on him now so i
was like poor guy if you're ever
watching reach out i'll let you know
what to do next because i have been down
that road um
and but thinking back i realized wow
every single girl in that friend group
covered for her um they were all really
nice to me like oh jared it's so nice to
see you and you know touchy feely and
flirty and
and thinking back i'm i'm thinking i
don't know if she was trying to get me
like bait me into a situation where
cheating could possibly occur which i
think that was likely an option um
because of plot
plausible deniability on her part or for
her to to give her a reason to say okay
yeah now the marriage is definitely over
um oh and by the way i'm dating the
younger brother but that entire night
and they invited me to mini family
events where it's the same large very
large latin friend group
for for almost a year no one said a
single word to me although everyone knew
what was going on i kind of suspected it
and when i brought it up i always got
from the friend group i got the oh my
god you're insecure you're jealous uh
you shouldn't be a guy like that and
eventually one of the cousins
invited me out to beers beers he's like
hey bro um i can't sit on this any
longer like she's been with this guy the
entire time you guys have been married
there's actually multiple guys in the
situation did you guys live apart or did
you live together we lived together at
first and then once she got the green
card she took off and went and lived at
the uncle in town saying that oh uh
there was a problem she was banging the
other guy
yeah i i assumed she was doing that the
the whole time
there's a point where she had gone to
miami prior to that where i had found
out later like uh obviously after we're
already married uh
found out later that she had taken some
money of mine that i gave her to give us
a place in texas and took it to miami
she went to ultra i met up with an
ex-boyfriend from columbia and
and swore that nothing happened i heard
the stories like all my friends are
hooking up and they're all doing drugs
and they're all drunk but me and in my
head i'm like you're just sitting there
like you're just like oh i'm having a
terrible time because i don't partake in
such activities like well no
hindsight's always 20 20 but looking
back it's like well no obviously
obviously you're a part of that
environment too i've been to me i've
been to plenty of music festivals like
we're all in that mindset um
but yeah i've hearing some of these
stories like don't do long-distance
relationships those never work um if you
catch her pulling away obviously you
need to be the one to always end
interactions with women as guys but
another one that i hadn't thought of in
a while until this topic came up was uh
look at her friend group be really wary
of them um inevitably especially if
you're in like a long term relationship
you're going to end up in some sort of
social environment where it's her and
all of her girlfriends whether you're
picking her up from somewhere or there's
there's a brunch and you're like oh
yeah i'll come by or whatever um and pay
attention to them because i i've seen it
go both ways with the friends like
they're all kind of wild they're party
girls they're all drinkers they're all
telling crazy stories but when it comes
to your girl like oh she's an angel like
she's the only angel in the group
or
now i date girls where when i meet the
friend group like all of them are in
long-term committed relationships the
girls are all in the guy's frame so i
like seeing signs like that too or i
date more of kind of like it's a green
flag for sure
yeah or not like i tell guys um like
don't go for the girl who's awake at 3am
go for the girl who's up at 6 a.m who's
out on the jogging trail with you
those girls like fit girls they have
friends that are usually healthier girls
are into wellness or any sort of that
stuff like they'll get into some woo-woo
type philosophies but normally you can
find a better uh quality there and so
yeah they want to deal with some woo-woo
energy crystals and some becky in
her friend circle telling her that uh
she hates you because you walked across
the room to get water
yeah that is absolutely ridiculous um i
i have had that happen before though not
not that situation i've had i've had it
where their roommates have like seen me
naked before or something i'm just like
oh oh god but um that's why i say always
look at the reaction of the friends
especially when you're meeting a friend
group for the first time
their the friend's reaction towards you
will tell you how the girl really feels
about you and they'll cover for each
other but you need to learn how to look
through that stuff and i suppose that's
my two cents from my uh my personal
origin story i'd forgotten all about
that until this topic came up and a lot
of these guys are telling the same
stories that we've all experienced as
men so yeah look out for these things
thanks bro see you later take care
you